[Music]
welcome to
session 49 of the worlds of speculative
fiction series
this time we are going back to an author
who we looked at in the very first year
of the series when it was just getting
started and that is philip k dick
at that time the theme that i oriented
the
talk around was philip k dick's
alternative america so we looked at you
know some of
my favorite ones like man in the high
castle
uh through scanner darkly uh and also
the valles
related ones which you know there's
there's quite a lot of stuff going on
with that particularly in the last years
of
of dick's um writing and so
we we looked at those and we talked
about certain themes but philip k
dick is such a wide-range author
when it comes just to his sci-fi stuff
not even to mention
his realistic novels or this massive
you know exegesis of philip k dick which
is quite interesting as well
that i thought we needed some some theme
to focus
uh our talk about today as well and so i
chose two key ideas
colonization of space
and insanity or mental disorders and how
these come together
and i think the the guiding impulse that
i had for that
was the the story which we're going to
be looking at
three stigmata of palmer eldritch where
you have these people out there
unfortunately drafted
into being colonists and their lives
just suck
and the way that they get out of it is
through
using this this hallucinogenic and it
may even go beyond that sort of drug
that allows them to participate in the
life of perky pat
and the the other people involved in
these these uh
frameworks as as they have them and
we'll talk more about that in just just
a minute
and so i thought that would work well
and i was also you know at the time
going back and reading the martian time
slip obviously that takes place on mars
and has to do with
various discussions about insanity
and then of course i remembered you know
clans of the alphane
moon so i thought we've got a good
series going on here what else could i
fill it out with
so we've got clans the alfine moon which
we're going to talk about in just a bit
i've got these library of america
volumes which is actually i'll tell you
a little story about how i got into dick
and
became a big [ __ ] that's the name of
fans in just a little
little bit but this one has um
uh here we go a maze of death in it
very important story as it turns out
within
dick's oof uh then in this four novels
from the 1960s
we have three stigmata of palmer
eldritch
and then finally in this one
it begins with the martian time
slip this one also has scanner darkly
which has
i think become my favorite dick novel
it's replaced man in the high castle
although
flow my tears the policeman said it's
pretty pretty awesome too
and so we're going to be looking at the
the narrative worlds of these
stories and talking about some of the
commonalities between them
and some of the differences obviously
each of them has its own
narrative world so we're putting
together kind of a composite picture
i also in lieu of engaging in the usual
biographical stuff that we do
in this i thought it would be cool in
also instead of going to interviews if
we would go
to the exegesis which rarely gets talked
about
i think in part because it's such a
massive tome
and i think the people who do talk about
it tend to be
the ones that dick might not have liked
the
sort of you know seeing seeing things
and everything sort of surface level
hippie
stuff what dick thought he was doing in
his stories was was pretty deep and that
is reflected in discussions of those
stories
in the exegesis so we're going to talk
about that so we've got a lot to do
in this we're gonna we're gonna look at
each of the narrative worlds
we're gonna talk about some of the key
philosophical themes that are being
raised we're gonna look at the exegesis
itself and what dick has to say and
we're going to
try to do all of this in about 90
minutes so that after this
for those who are watching this as it
premieres
they can participate in a video
conferencing session going deeper into
this
with a friend of mine who's coming in
who is himself a
psychologist and has a lot to tell us
about the diagnosis that
dick is using and how those have changed
over time and our understanding
of that so that's going to be a lot of
fun if you're watching this
after the premiere you know you've got
all the discussions that are happening
in the course of this i do want to
mention i promised
to tell a little bit of my own story
about how i became a [ __ ]
and really got into dick's works
so it actually happened
with this this particular
volume i won't say this particular book
because this is what
got me into reading him but i will say
something about you know you see this
beautiful
um cover and and you know there's if
you've ever been to
a bookstore and gone to the section
where they have philip k dick
you've seen lots and lots and lots of
novels
of this sort so i
you know i i heard people referencing
philip k dick and i used to go to this
uh this great alternative bookstore when
i was in
carbondale and i was a graduate student
they had all these books lined up
and everybody who talked about dick i i
you know you say you can't judge a book
by its cover but i was
judging the book by the people who read
it and most of them were [ __ ] in
the wrong sense of the term they're kind
of pretentious
or they were you know kind of hippie
dippy and
i just hear them talking about oh man
you need to read philip k dick and i'd
be like
if you're you're in a dick i'm i'm not
into dick and
so you know i i didn't read philip k
dick when i could have and then
i actually this this was not the first
book of his that i read
it was um do androids dream of electric
sheep
because i'd really loved you know the
movie blade runner i saw it as
a teenager and i thought it was really
cool and
a friend of mine who was an
english graduate student went on to
become an english professor at some
small college in missouri he had a copy
of do android's dream of electric sheep
that he had used for one of his classes
where he'd been required to teach it
he hated philip k deck he thought this
was garbage right
and so he's like do you want this book
otherwise i'm going to throw it out and
i was like
yeah i mean i guess i should find out
what the buzz is about and i like blade
runners so
sure i'll take it and at that time i
didn't read it i read it many years
later and i was like wow this
is uh some really great stuff but and
then i just kind of filed away in the
back of my mind
now when i was down in fayetteville
north carolina
this would have been 2008 i moved down
there
took a job and got into this you know
little
one bedroom apartment right by the
downtown
about three miles away from the
university where i was teaching
and it was a very very lonely time i
left my at that time
wife and children up in indiana
moved down there with you know books my
banjo
clothing and got ready to teach in one
of the most dysfunctional places i've
ever seen
i have seen a place more dysfunctional
than that recently but that's a that's a
whole other story
and i didn't know anybody but one of the
cool things about
living where i did was that the
fayetteville library
was you know maybe like five six blocks
from me
and their downtown library was pretty
great it was it was quite impressive
and i was you know i was wandering
around through the
it might have been through the novel
sections or the sci-fi section
and i came across this and i was like
you know maybe i'll give
philip k dick a try this has got five
novels in it if i don't like one i can
just jump ahead to the next one these
library of america editions are
really a national treasure quite frankly
and so i i remember it was a hot day i
had the the screen door open the windows
open
and i'm sitting there on my um
uh you know crappy futon that i don't
even remember where i got this
oh somebody had thrown it was throwing
it out i i took it and i used that as my
couch
and i remember reading martian time
slip at one hit just like sitting down
and reading it all the way through
because it was so good
that i was like oh man i gotta find out
what happens next now obviously i'd get
up to you know like get myself a
drink and you know have a little
something to eat but i
read the whole thing and then i was like
wow that was
that was awesome let me read the next
one i started on dr blood money which is
pretty good too
i'm not as big of a fan of it i haven't
read it for a while but
i think you know dick has written better
stuff and then i started reading these
other
ones in it you know on subsequent days
you know
now wait for last year um
flow my tears the policeman said uh
and then finally uh scanner darkly and
so within a week i'd read all of these
and i was like wow i got
i got to get more of this this stuff
unfortunately there it was quite quite
easily available
i have read my way through i think
pretty much
all of the novels that philip k dick has
written
and i think most of the short stories
although i may have missed some
doubtless i've forgotten some stuff but
over the years over the you know so that
would have been
12 13 years ago over the
this decade i have really gotten into
his work i think he's a
an amazing author and one of the things
just to end this that i really find
quite interesting
about about dick is that
he is an author who
brings in ideas from philosophy
in a very deliberate way ideas from
religion and religions in
in a similar way ideas from psychology
he's a very well read person
and he's he's not just bringing these in
to provide a little bit of seasoning
like you know
i'll give you a prime example there's a
lot of people because they're jumping on
the bandwagon about stoicism these days
they write a novel in which there's a
stoic but you read it and you're like
man this person hasn't really spent much
time with
marcus and epictetus and seneca let
alone any of the other
authors as well dick dick read this
stuff
because it was and this is this comes
out in the the exit jesus
this was vital for him he wanted to
figure out his own screwed up life
and personality and relationships and
whether there was a greater meaning to
things
the political uh developments and system
that we were in the wars that we were
involved in
he's trying to figure all these things
out and science fiction is really his
medium
rather than his absolute calling
he you know he is a great craftsman but
he's interested in bringing these ideas
in to to work with them
and i think he provides us through the
through the characters and what they say
and what they do and what they think
and what they learn he provides us with
interesting windows on what the meaning
of these
philosophical ideas or
opportunities or experiences and
religious and psychological what what
they
really could mean and he does so
through these people without being a
buttinsky kind of person
you know being the narrator who has it
all
figured out he's this is something that
i find incredibly
attractive about about dick's work that
will probably have me
coming back to him over and over again
over the course of my life so
let's talk now about the actual
novels themselves let's talk
first about some aspects of the world
building
that philip k dick is engaged in
and i would say there's no absolutely
consistent narrative universe that you
could shoehorn
all of dick's novels into it's not like
you know
they're all part of one vast system
and we'll talk about you know why that
couldn't be the case with some reference
to the the exegesis in just a bit
but at this point i want to spend you
know sort of some surface level time
just talking about these these uh
novels for those of you who may not have
read them
and want to know something about them so
i chose as one of the
key themes for this colonization
of of space right colonization in
particular of the solar system
but it can also extend further
and we could take each of these four
novels and arrange them kind of along a
continuum
so i would say you know
i was tempted to put clans of the
alphine moon first but actually i would
place
a maze of death first at one end of the
spectrum
because as it turns out they now they
they think that they're on you know some
some
colony planet originally turns out
they're actually on
earth but an earth that has managed to
colonize
significant parts of the galaxy and then
we get the big
twist and i'm going to give you a
spoiler here they're actually in a ship
that is is circling a star and there's
no way for them to
get out of that their their
communication apparatus is screwed up
and they're trying to figure out what
they're going to do
and they're creating an imaginary world
uh an imaginary landscape you could say
or narrative universe
in which they are are spending time and
actually discharging some of their
aggressivity right so they're out
um in the middle of nowhere in a in a
universe a galaxy a system
that is not even alien it's just
there right and that's one end of
colonization totally unsuccessful
colonization
at the other end i think we could talk
about martian time
slip where um mars has successfully been
colonized
and obviously people are living in some
hardship there's there's a you know like
a black market for
things that people want to get that's
that's a significant part of the plot
and you know there's mountains that the
un is going to
buy up and then sell off and develop and
that plays
an important role in it as well and it's
very you know
mars-centric there's some discussion of
earth but there's no discussion of like
uh we're
going off to you know uh alfine systems
or anything like that so we've got these
two
and then we've got you know three
stigmata of palmer eldritch
where palmer eldritch has gone
outside of the
solar system but all of the colonization
on the part of
human beings is pretty much within the
solar system
so he represents somebody who's you know
he's gone off to the nearest
uh non-you know terran
system and he's engaged with some of the
people there it turns out that he's
actually brought something back with him
and it's not just a lichen
so we'll talk about that in a bit and
then we have the
clans of the alphane moon
where they're within the the system
of the the alphanes and there's a moon
that was originally a hospital
base i guess you could say and it's
effectively become
a colony with these originally
insane patience of different sorts
forming into different clans and so
we've got a nice
sort of spread there and you know dick
doesn't worry an awful lot about
explaining how it is that we can travel
faster than light or anything
along those lines he's not preoccupied
with that he's much more interested
in the fact that we can have some sort
of colonization
process take place and what's really
interesting is that
human beings don't fundamentally change
by going out into space you know they
bring a lot of their
systems with them which then have to
adapt somewhat there's commerce is very
very important a lot of dick's
characters are connected with buying and
selling things or you know media
production or things like that
there's usually some sort of
governmental agency or process the u.n
plays a significant role
in in quite a few of these these stories
um and then they'll be like you know
aliens and the aliens can be very very
alien
uh they can be kind of a lot like us
but you know some sometimes surprising
you know for example
uh ganomedian slime mold plays an
important role
in clans of the alpha and moon some sort
of
thing from you know the stars
plays an important role in three
stigmata
the native uh martians play an important
role
in um the martian time
slip and actually i mean
there is an important kind of alien
although it turns out it's
not exactly what we think that plays
a significant role in maze of death and
so
you know human beings are trying to
do all the things that they have to do
very often under duress very under
very often under uh circumstances that
they don't control
and which they don't like and they want
to get out of
in one way or another and so let's talk
about
this in a little bit more detail so
let's let's start with clans of the
alpha moon um
i mentioned that it is a moon that plays
an important role here
and it was a moon that was um
originally a hospital base for mental
patients now why would you put all the
mental patients
on that that when that was never truly
explained in the story but that's okay
the dick is you know
playing around with some ideas and it's
uh there's a war
between the terrans you know the earth
people
and the alphanes who are kind of an
insectine
race prone to you know
risky decision making and all that and
what we have is an earth where
[Music]
non-human species can exist and live
some of them are under more scrutiny
some of them are under
less but they're all kind of forced into
ghetto-like conditions and that
is how the main character who we meet at
the very start of it
um you know uh
gets to to meet all of these these uh
actually
he's not the very first person who comes
in gabriel baines is but
uh here we go chuck rittersdorf um
winds up settling into this apartment in
a crappy part of town where all the
aliens live
right and as it turns out a a woman
who's a
a cop because she can do some important
um
things you know in terms of time so
you know that's that's one particular
universe we could say excuse me
and then we have um the moon itself
and in the you know the book actually
begins with a council meeting
where all of the representatives of
these different groups
are figuring out what they're going to
do and they're called things
like you know the heebs or
the depths or the mans or the pears and
all of these are named after different
ways
of being mentally ill
now you know they're using the term
psychosis in there we don't really use
that
psychosis and neurosis language
nowadays we talk in terms of mental
disorders but there's a lot of
things in here that do correspond to the
current dsm
categories and on this moon
once all the authorities left these
mental patients
effectively began running the asylum and
they turned it into not an asylum
and they work together to have a
more or less functioning society which
we'll talk about a bit more
later on so that's enough about world
building there
what about in the other things let's
talk about three stigmata
of palmer eldritch so the colonization
has taken place within the
solar system that we're all familiar
with and
pretty much nobody who is involved in
the colonization at least at the lower
level
wants to be doing it they have to be
drafted
and they're sent off you know to places
and they live in what are called
hovels and they live together and you
know they
they get depressed pretty easily because
of the crappiness
of their circumstances they're given all
sorts of resources by the
u.n and then this is happening so that
we can colonize space
because earth itself is getting way way
way too
hot and it's almost becoming unlivable
but people still want to stay on earth
rather than being stuck
out on a un hovel
in the colonies and they do projects
like digging you know
ditches for irrigation or having gardens
and they're given all sorts of
opportunities to do this
most of them find after a while they're
too depressed to really
carry out these these things as
colonists so the colonies are not
particularly
uh well-off or highly functioning
and uh you know the um
the one escape is this this thing that
that
the you know the characters early on
are involved with and these
are perky pat and her boyfriend
um they are able to you can buy these
dolls and you can buy these
these setups and you can buy all these
miniaturized consumer goods
and then you chew this um this gum
and the gum is you could say it's a
hallucinogenic but it allows people to
merge their minds and also to inhabit
the space of these these frameworks
with perky pat and the other people that
she's going to interact with
and her boyfriend and
you're doing it with with other other
people i mean you could be doing it with
other things as well you could imagine
like having you know
the old toy army men and having a war
going on or something like that but this
is what they're selling
and there are you know the the the main
characters are also involved with
pushing this this illegal drug that
allows people to
experience that now palmer eldritch
comes back
from a 10-year journey way out beyond
the solar system
to you know another solar system
and he comes back and his organization
is going to push
a different kind of hallucinogenic
that will allow a different kind of
experience that goes way
beyond this the reason why this this
experience is so important is
that is what allows these miserable
colonists to not hang themselves
and it's it's it's an integral part of
their life and an integral part of the
story
so that that's a good you know move then
to talking about
maze of death in the maze of death
until you know we get to the very end
what we have are a bunch of people and
they exist
in this uh you know
let's call it colonized portion of the
galaxy
in which humankind has encountered these
aliens
that live on what are called prayer
worlds and prayers
are efficacious within this narrative
universe because
religion itself has been now understood
in terms of actual experiences and and
systems that that work
and so you know there's there's a very
important theology developed
uh you know with spectroscopy uh you
know the person who writes the book that
everybody carries around
there there are characters who are like
praying to get you know transferred
somewhere else because their job sucks
or their life sucks and all that
and they all wind up taking these
one-way trip
little rockets essentially called
nosers and winding up on on a particular
planet that
they're supposed to establish a colony
on
right as martian time slip and um
what ends up happening is
they get killed off one by one by one
right and um they're they're told to
to transfer to this place it turns out
that they can't get uh what they're
supposed to have
uh in terms of instructions and things
just keep going
wrong they're on yeah that here we go
delmark o is is the name of the place
so they can't get off the planet uh
something is preying on them there's
this mysterious building in the
background
and there's weird stuff happening
they're all kind of maladapted
individuals trying to figure out where
they fit in
and then as the story develops
it turns out they're not on delmac oh at
all
they're on earth they're on an earth
that has been
largely abandoned because people used it
up and then
flew away as a matter of fact the only
people who exist on earth are the ones
that are called the ostriches
meaning insane people and then the
guards who have to
like monitor these these ostriches and
so they've been
on earth and experiments have been
carried out on them
their memories are kind of false
they didn't actually fly from all these
other places they've been on earth
and uh you know turns out that um
there's you know more to the story than
they they thought
but that's only part of the story
because as it turns out
all of that is effectively a group
hallucination
none of it's real it's all being created
for
people in this ship that has
lost its ability to go anywhere else
and is starting to run low on certain
supplies like coffee
and doesn't have a communication
apparatus so they can't call anybody
and they're out in the middle of space
circling a
star that's not going to do them any
good using
a virtual reality toy
to keep themselves sane and that
is is what the true
narration of it the true world that
they're in so there's
there's a double whammy there right
you've got the
well we're all colonists on this this
world wait that way out and who knows
where in the galaxy
no we're actually here on earth and
we're all a bunch of nutters
no we're actually people who are
not insane but are getting there and
we've been tapped into this
ship's computer to have an artificial
reality in which we participate yet
one more time in a massive cycle
there's one other novel we need to talk
about of course and that
is the martian time slip
here mars has been colonized and we have
a whole bunch of different characters
who are all doing different things
including a young boy named manfred
who is is seemingly not able to
communicate with with other people
um but one of the main characters
actually figures out how uh
he he might be able to to communicate
with him jack
is able to do that and
there's you know a number of other
people arnie kott who's
kind of a union boss and runs a lot of
a lot of uh things and has a lot of
access to stuff
and there's all these different people
kind of working across purposes
with each other jack's dad is a big
[Music]
you know financier and speculator and
he's out there to try to
get you know get an investment in this
area will allow them to make a ton of
money
and so you know they're on a mars which
it's not as bad as what's going on in
three stigmata but
it it does kind of suck for a lot of
them but it can be okay
you know arnie cut gets to you know
take a steam bath and enjoy all this
black market food and
have you know his his wife who he's
divorced but still engages with in
business ventures and talks with and
then have all these mistresses
and you know there's there's uh all
sorts of other people
trying to live a life there as well and
eat you know there's different
settlements too
uh for different kinds of people
different nationalities different
different groupings and they're all
sort of you know working at cross
purposes with each other the other thing
i should mention about that too
is that there is a essentially automated
school it's got these similacra human
beings
and they could be anything from like you
know uh mark twain
to to you know whoever else you want
teaching the kids and jack is
is one of the people who goes in and
fixes them so
jack has also had a you know he's lapsed
into psychosis before
um and and that's that's one of his his
key
worries um and there's a lot of
discussion about
you know the nature of reality going on
in this
in these narrative worlds all across
uh these different novels so that gives
you at least a sense of
where these are situated and what is
going on and what these people
are trying to focus on what their their
drives are what their interests are
we should talk now before we get into
the discussion about
mental illness itself about what
dick himself has to say about
all these different novels and and how
they fit into his
his ideas there are many many sources
that we could go to for
understanding philip k dick and his
stories
including the many interviews that he's
given
and other writings we could also talk
about ursula k leguin and her own
uh interactions with him which he
mentions
in this thing that i you know i'm going
to bring up right now the exegesis
of philip k dick which is edited by
jackson and
latham dick left behind a number of
pages of manuscript that are edited into
this
volume and it stems from an
experience that he had and a whole set
of insights and you can see
dick attempting to make sense out of
his own past work where his work is
going some of the key themes and
you could say a cosmic drama that he
views himself
as involved in and one of the
passages that i wanted to bring up quite
early
has to do with um you know
the the ancient period you could say he
says
i was consciously deliberately
interested in that period i was in my
early 20s and read about it a lot
at the expense of being a rounded person
but my unconscious for all
its obsessions with the theoretical
material of that period is hard-headed
intrude
and wants everything it comes up with
applied in the most practical way
if it shows me the golden rectangle it
does so in order to call me with that
ultimately aesthetically
balanced sight it has a firm therapeutic
purpose
there is a utilization of all of its
abstract material for genuine purposes
for me by and large now here's
where he says something about aristotle
and philosophy
it is it is a tutor to me as aristotle
was to alexander
which makes me wonder why it is grooming
and shaping me this way tutoring me in
the exact fashion employed by the greeks
philosophy for real ends for final
causes
as aristotle would have put it for
something lying ahead
and not as an idle pastime as an end in
itself
the ennobling and elevating education is
altering me
and i would presume that when it is
finished i
having become changed will act upon the
improved character which i've acquired
not on the knowledge direct
as if on enlarged memory banks but upon
the basis of my matured and elevated
character
i know this whole process sees ahead
because i have caught sight of its clear
perception
down the web of time seen with it for a
while it knows what is ahead and acts
accordingly i'm sure it has a final
purpose in mind
for which this is careful preparation
so that's kind of an interesting idea
there and and part of what we see
happening in this exegesis
among all the other things that he's
bringing in is a consideration of what's
actually
happening in his his own narrative works
so here's um one thing
that he's he's saying that i think is is
kind of interesting
he's referring to his own books and he
he talks about them in very elliptical
ways
i joint three stigmata
ubik and maze now three stigmatas three
stigmatas palmer eldritch
and maize is maze of death are the same
novel
written over and over again the
characters are all out cold and lying
around together on the floor mass
hallucinating a world why have i written
this
up at least five times and so he says
because as i discovered in 374 when i
experienced anamnesis which is
this sort of recovering of of knowledge
remembered i'm really an apostolic
christian saw ancient rome
this is our condition we're mass
hallucinating this 1970s world
what's got to be gotten over is the
false idea that hallucination is a
private matter now that's that's an
interesting thing
to say right hallucination uh is usually
viewed
as something that the insane person or
you know the
person under the influence of drugs or
something like that the psychotropized
person you could say does by themselves
it takes them
out of this world of reality and
supplants
that with images and whatever else from
a private reality and dick is saying
yeah plenty of times that's the case
there's a lot of druggies and dopers who
are doing that but that's not the case
here much later on
in the exegesis um there's another one i
had marked out and wanted to discuss in
particular
here we go he says
[Applause]
um he's talking about the the gnostics
and the gnosis and he says that uh
living information is is part of what
he's experiencing
um the thing that he calls zebra an
information virus and artificial
intelligence something that intrudes
into our world which is which is not a
world
of genuine reality so he goes on and he
says
here we go this all goes back to what
i'd figured out before
it is the irreal versus the real the
inauthentic versus the authentic
that is that which is in parentheses
being
in contrast to that which only seems so
it is to me epistemology which is
involved rootedness in truth
versus the lie throughout all my writing
including the man in the high castle
especially there is a preoccupation with
fakes and the fake
fake worlds fake humans fake objects
fake time
etc the authentic human versus the
android or reflex machine is the essence
of it
again and again i attempt to formulate
criteria for what is fake and what is
not fake in every area
from a comic book to a world leader to a
girlfriend to an entire universe
things are seldom what they seem right
it has to do with reality testing which
is related to another theme of mine
mental illness right one of the key
themes that we're going to be
discussing here shortly
which brings in hallucinations and
deliberate deception
for example uh penultimate truth the
simulacra game players of titans novels
i usually overlook
and mental illness brings in martian
time slip dr blood money the simulacra
clans clans of the alpine
the the alphine moon so virtually all my
writing interlocks at this
sub strap now he goes on and says
i count 21 books including story
collections in which fake versus real is
in some way the topic
22 if japed is included the man who
japed right
plus a number of unanthologized stories
in
sheep that is you know the android's
dream of electric sheep
fake versus real operates on five
different levels he says and he talks
about the man in the high castle
all of these and i'll just read you what
these are you may find them interesting
so
in uh do androids dream of electric
sheep fake
synthetic moods that are electronically
generated fake animals fake humans that
is androids including fake memories and
identities
a fake savior the old wino movie bit
player
fake police station not in the movie of
course
part of the world right in
uh the man in the high castle uh we've
got fake world fake perceptions fake
volition
fake memories fake identity all of this
are our themes that
dick thinks is really central and he's
seeing this in
his works right i i've been writing this
stuff i'm working these ideas out you
know let me
take these on now there were a number of
ways in which his his books were brought
together including the ones that were
looking at in in this this session
so i wanted to bring up a few of those
passages where he explicitly connects
them
together and it's it's not all of them
it's uh you know for example he's not
going to talk about clans of the
elf and moon very much in the exegesis
but he is going to talk about um
here we go uh
he tells us that that um maze of death
and three stigmata of palmer aldrich are
connected to each other
so he says the gnostic contribution
which
maze of death makes is the idea of a
totally
untenable reality glossed over by a mass
wish fulfillment hallucination shared by
everyone
and a salvific entity who can extricate
you right out of that prison-like
world so the maze here he's got sort of
a schema
prison-like world glossed over by
illusion salvific intercessor who can
and does extricate you
induced amnesia now who is the
intercessor
well there's actually the whole theology
of that in maze of death
and it's also in some respect the the
machine itself that's being
used to to create this this alternate
reality
virtual reality that the people are
losing themselves in
for quite some time in three stigmata of
palmer eldritch invasion penetration of
our world by a deity
who can become everyone via the host a
mass and here's a term that he uses
theolepsy god sort of grabbing on to you
right so and then he brings up ubik
which you may have
read or may not have read which is also
a great one he says salvific information
penetrating through the walls of our
world by an entity with personality
representing a life and a
reality supporting quasi-living force
and he says we can collate
these three novels a little bit earlier
in
in this section he says um
what do you get if as leguin ursula k le
guin
who was a correspondent to him and
actually went to high school with him
you take a group of my novels and
stories and fit them together especially
the three picked up
by bantam theolepsy the gnostic
gnosis slipping through reality the
world is illusion concealing another but
real world
in parentheses maze what an aggregate
message these three novels
add up to when i recently re-read
stigmata i saw it for what it was a
penetrating
acute and exhaustive study of the
miracle of trans-substantiation
however simply transposing
here we go reversing the bipolarities of
good and evil
what the novel contemplated was the
startling notion
that imbibing of the sacred host
culminated for the imbiber and
eventually becoming the deity
of which the host was the supernatural
manifestation right
and so you know that that's uh quite an
interesting set of speculations there on
his part
we also have another discussion where he
says
three stigmata and maize are total
opposites
in maze reality is a hallucination there
is a real world behind it but in three
stigmata
hallucination becomes real not real
becomes hallucination and thereby
departs so we want to keep that in the
back of our mind
as well and then
here's another interesting
discussion as well along
similar lines he
tells us
expands it a little bit more he says
that
uh if stigmata
mays ubik tears flow my tears the
policeman said right
and scanner scanner darkly are real
as one er narrative
you are right one single primal
narrative
the true picture the true full picture
begins to take shape
but all must be read all five scanner is
crucial if left out we cannot fathom why
we can't see the world of
tears and then he says the matter must
be approached through the realization of
occlusion
to the true prison situation the result
of the spinner of spurious worlds
stigmata and maize
and then the salvific entity can be
understood in its work appreciated ubik
so the logical sequence is you know
scanner occlusion
tears what is really there which we
don't see stigmata
who occludes us at spurious worlds maze
how occluded negative hallucination and
then finally ubik
the salvific entity and how it works
so you know that that's uh quite
interesting
as as well
then a little bit uh later here's
another
passage i wanted to bring up dick is
reflecting on his own
work and it's in its themes and he says
that um you know this world that we're
in is
is in some respects not the real world
and we want to get be
behind it or you know get to what is
what is genuinely real
so he says um unable to deal with
external space that is unable to rebel
i have turned to inner space to
exploring it which too is a political
act so my writing
involving inner space is covertly
subversive it teaches secret ways to
rebel
that's why the whole psychedelic
movement of the 60s was a threat to the
authorities
this was the area of the subversive
threat i posed my studies of inner space
in fact my conceptions of inner space
differing from person to person
is very radical and politically
subversive and he goes on and he says
i broke through into an absolute space
such as is not even known
following the disappearance of the
hermetics and he goes on he says this
absolute space
involves knowledge and power over time
and that time can no longer extinguish
the person
going down he says there really is
something very subversive about
ubek as well as i i in the sky
and stigmata and martian time slip
now isn't that interesting it's one of
the few places where he actually does
talk about
the martian time slip in that how is the
martian time slip
story subversive well we'll get to that
in a bit this is a bit of
foreshadowing there there are a few
other points that i do want to bring up
from this that i think will be
illuminative
right and let me jump to
one of them that is about midway through
so he um he's got this long section
where he talks about how how these could
be arranged in relation to each other
this is shortly after
the discussion about the er narrative
right
and so he says here's the correct
sequence
scanner tears stigmata of thristigmat of
palmer eldritch
maze maze of death ubik do
androids all right um a story called
imposter
which got turned into a interesting
little show at one point
faith of and then every other relevant
story
he says and then i subjective private
worlds
and he says scanner is the weary final
point our minds are screwed up
it isn't just a case of pseudo worlds
and this links with it and then he says
all in all my writing cast out on the
fact of even possibility of
knowing actual reality because our minds
have been [ __ ] over
some evidence that his tears points to
the real situation being prison-like
but maize and especially ubik point to a
supernatural
salvific interventive power although
stigmata seems to say an evil magician
deities in control of our
worlds and heads right so a little bit
further he goes on and and he says all
right here's
here's the the arrangement that we have
um
so he's lining all of his works up in
some sort of overarching narrative
that's supposed to make sense out of all
of these things
he's got another similar schema where he
says the theme of their all
out of it appears and then he numbers
off all these different things again
i joint
the man in the high castle time slip
here he talks about the martian time
slip
and what is he what is he talking about
there he gives us a description
fake psychotic realities that's
that's the thematization that's
happening stigmata
fake malignant realities right
uh so fake psychotic realities how how
can they be fake realities
and then how can they be fake malignant
realities well they're not what they
pretend to be but there is a reality
there
ubik maze they're jointly hallucinating
a spurious world
tears and then scanner and then he says
secondarily
false perceptions appear in
clans clans of the elf and moon
psychotic perceptions that compete
than game players and cosmic puppets so
he says
so one dozen novels and too many stories
to count
narrate a message of one world obscuring
or replacing another
in parentheses real one spurious memory
memories hallucinated irreal worlds the
message reads don't believe what you see
it's enthralling and destructive
evil snare under it is a totally
different world even placed differently
along the linear time axis
and your memories are fake to jibe with
the fake world inner
and outer congruency so you know he's
saying this is this is what my works are
really about and exploring and not just
doing so for
you know the audience as if i have all
the insights they're doing it for me
philip k dick thinks that his
unconscious mind is contributing to all
of that and so
the last discussion that i want to bring
up here is
is from folder 36
and he talks first about a dream that
he's having
and then he talks about the computer
punched tape and the computer of the
purses
9 in maze of death which can't be read
intrinsically
but gives rise to the world of flesh or
nature which again
in turn gives rise to the artificial
world of mechanical
electronic concepts or constructs
and here he says something really quite
interesting
so dick thinks that
what he's doing is in some way connected
with
ancient christianity and salvific
religions
and he also thinks it's connected with
platonism
so if we go on he says
here we go no one
three layers or levels are represented
no one wishes to take seriously the
deepest one except me
the logos the word is represented that
which is written gives rise to the
living world creatures nature
which in turn gives rise to our
artificial environment if we place
ourselves in the top world the
artificial construct
we're totally walled off we have no
knowledge or contact with the logos
substratum nor if it's called to our
attention can we
see any merit in it if two
uh the this you know the second level is
real and rational
one is not it's even hard not impossible
to comprehend
two when we start with the third level
which is given in the dream as a
starting point of view
two itself is difficult to explain how
does it relate to three but at least it
isn't crazy
the way one looks one is the the
genuine reality he says put another way
one gives rise to three via two a
fascinating thought
so the origins of the technological
world the manufacture the constructed
lies ultimately in a hidden
sort of hidden punched out tape just as
the false world of
delmac o in maze of death arises from
perseus 9's computer
2 the world of flesh and nature totally
hides the true origin of three
it's by a thorough study of the
relationship between these
the relationship between one the bottom
level and two can be understood
as one is to two two is to three we live
somewhere between
two and three never as the person's crew
never suspected while in their
polyencephalic fusion suspecting one
what the dream reveals is not just that
we like they have a punched out computer
tape programming
us but tells us too that it is christian
in fact biblical in essence christianity
is our punched out tape he says
all the thousands of large written pages
of books which i saw the books
themselves isn't a dream
were our punched out computer tape the
source of our natural living world which
totally obscures its origins and causes
so he goes on and on and he says
um even more revealingly as a tv image
is to human human is to logos
i should imag i should examine the
profound implications that the maze
model simulating a shared reality is an
accurate model of our own world so the
story that he's telling in maze of death
whether he intended it to at the time is
telling us
the story of our own condition
right and he says put another way
plato's concept of the real world of
forms
was a primitive pre-technological
attempt
to describe what is more accurately
described by the logos theory which
resembles
what i described in maze of death
so isn't that interesting he goes on a
little bit later and he talks about
you know the theology of the maze of
death he says it certainly is odd
that in maze i assigned to the
manufacturer
the power to roll back time though
however a closer scrutiny of the delmac
old world and maze would show that
he has that power due to the illusory
quality
of that world perhaps if it were real
time
even by god could not be rolled back put
another way
if you discover that in your world time
can be rolled back
you can correctly deduce your world is
illusory and then what is exposed when
that time by the deity is rolled back
right so there's some really interesting
discussions happening in this and this
this opens up to us
a possibility for reading dick in in a
you know a way aligned with his own
reading of himself
i would suggest that we don't have to go
along with him on that
but that uh this can help us to
understand his own views on these
stories and it helps us understand
the theme not just of colonization i
would say colonization provides us with
sort of a pretext
the real theme is that of insanity
and the many different kinds of insanity
and
whether or not we might put it this way
crazy people are really crazy or
whether in some cases that craziness
not in all cases but in some cases that
that insanity might be the rational
reaction to the world that they're
experiencing that they're in and in some
cases provide them with access to
something
going deeper going further it could also
be something
threatening as well as we're going to
talk about with palmer
eldritch before we
delve into each of these four novels and
look at the roles in which
what do we want to call it insanity
mental illness
uh disorders you know all these sorts of
things that we can we can
talk about before we look at that in
each of these
stories we want to say a few things in
general
about dick's approach we've seen that
reality
and fakes and uh you know mental states
and how people are reacting to things
and whether they have control over
themselves or whether something else is
pushing them these are all key themes
running throughout dick's works not just
because
he thinks they're you know cool to play
with in a sort of literary way
but because he is he's really centrally
concerned
with these himself and one thing that we
can say
is that you know dick doesn't do a lot
of
narration of the sort where he's the
omniscient
third person narrator telling us
precisely what's happening arranging
all of the pieces instead what's
happening is generally third person
but it's it's very focused on the
characters
and they reveal what's going on either
through interior dialogue through their
thoughts
or through dialogue with with other
characters and a lot of the exposition
in the works happens through the
things that characters say and the
attitudes that they take
so you know where can you say well this
is dick
speaking and not just a character
you know i think as with dostoyevsky
or as with you know ursula k le guin or
you know
shakespeare a lot of these great authors
it's you know we have to be kind of
careful
about what we're attributing directly
to the author and narrator
and what is being said by the characters
which may or may not represent
his his thoughts on things and
you know another thing that we should
think about as well is that there are
some characters who are very sure of
themselves
sometimes they're actually you know kind
of kind of off base because of that
but many characters within dick's worlds
are suffering in one way or another and
you know they they may be misled they
may not like their circumstances they
could be depressed they could be
you know jumping from opportunity to
opportunity that that's pretty
clearly um you know a part of of many of
their lives
and you know some of the characters are
diagnosed by somebody or another in them
as
as being insane or somebody's like well
that's definitely a person who's
acting this way and there's also a lot
of discussions of mental
illness and and you know why they're
what the grounds of it it
are and what the effects of them are
but it's a continuum characters who
may appear to be completely out of it
turn out to be
in tune with what's going on and and
vice versa characters who are
managing quite well sometimes crumble
under
new circumstances and so that's that's
important to
keep in mind which is like you know real
life
another key thing that we want to keep
in mind
is that the terminology that dick is
using
has changed over time so you know
here in the united states we're up to
dsm
5 and some of the things that he's
talking about are not recognized
by that dsm others
are are treated in different ways people
have
new theories about you know what
causes or constitutes this disorder
there's a lot of concerns about you know
whether
talking about mental illness is ableist
at all and that's just not on dick's
radar
so you know because it's a different
time and a different
framework we could say one thing that i
think you really definitely want to keep
in mind
is that at least within you know it was
kind of a worldwide phenomenon but i
think you could say at least within the
american
uh psychological and psychiatric
establishment
there is this conception of their
instead of talking about disorders
and having a whole bunch of different uh
uh
you know subsections there was a general
notion of neurosis
and then psychosis and you know the one
is where the person is still
able to you know kind of function
psychosis well you still could kind of
function but they're much further
into the sphere of of uh you know
you could say noticeable insanity
and so when when they're using these
terms like for example
when dick is using
autism to talk about manfred's
situation in the martian time slip that
may not be exactly what people think of
as autism today where we talk about this
whole spectrum
and all these different ways in which
people uh
you know could be diagnosed as autistic
so keep that in mind as well
and the last thing that i do uh want to
bring up
is so you know
mental illness is usually viewed
as a something wrong with the person
who's mentally ill
as maladaptive as you know
a working out of of
trauma that that happened to them that
damaged them in some way
or you know something is wrong
organically and they just can't fit in
they've got certain
problems that that can't be resolved and
there is
there are a lot of people like that in
dick's worlds but there are
also some who precisely
you you can't even say precisely because
of their mental illness
uh they they have this you know ability
to see something that that other people
don't
see it's rather they're mentally ill
because they're
seeing things that other people are not
seeing and it might be true and it might
be false it might
be that society itself or the conditions
that people are living under is
is what's making people nuts you could
say right
you know deranging them in certain ways
it's so it's not just an individual
thing but also individual choices matter
and the positions people take matter and
you know relationships
matter and there are some people that we
encounter in this who are genuinely
bad or even evil and they could be you
know mentally ill as well
so you know there there isn't this like
neat packaging
you could say of mental illness either
in a psychiatric psychological way or
in a moral way within dick's stories
which again reflects real life pretty
well and i think that's that's part of
what we want to
turn to so you know the two books that
we brought up
primarily from the exegesis i'm going to
look at those
last so let's look at the two that don't
get mentioned as often
in the exegesis and that would be clans
of the alpine moon
and martian time slip and actually let's
let's think about martian time slip
first um there you know the the
things that are being talked about the
most are
the autism of manfred
and the psychosis
of of jack boland right so
jack winds up uh
going to this school which is being
developed well it's not being developed
it's already developed and
it's a bunch of robots essentially who
talk to the kids
and he's supposed to observe this this
this uh
particular robot for a while named
kindly dad and kindly dad invites jack
to talk to him
about what's going on and jack says
you know kindly dad you know what
schizophrenia is and he says
i think i've got a pretty good idea
jackie and he goes on and he says
here we go schizophrenia is one of the
most pressing problems human
civilization has ever faced
frankly kindly dad i emigrated to mars
because of my schizophrenic episode
when i was 22 and worked for corona
corporation i was cracking up i had to
move out of a complex
urban environment and into a simpler one
a primitive frontier environment with
more
freedom and he goes on and he says i
think this public school and you
teaching machines are going to rear
another generation of schizophrenics
the descendants of people like me who
are making a fine adaptation
to this new planet you're going to split
the psyches of these children because
you're teaching them
to expect an environment which doesn't
exist for them it doesn't exist back on
earth
now it's obsolete and you know that he
goes on
and um you know there's some other
interesting
notes there but i want to jump ahead a
little bit to where
bolin jack bolan is is uh talking about
um some other things that are that are
happening
so there's this this uh
party that they they have and
bolin has another schizophrenic episode
and winds up you know seeing everything
is as they say doubled as manfred is
going to talk about it
but what ends up happening is he sees
the different
people as if they're not really people
they're they're actually
machines like that like the machines in
the school and
um you know this this scares the hell
out of him and and bothers him
and he can't really explain it except
for you know the woman that he's
he's seeing who has a brother who
suffered from something
similar now there's also manfred right
and
so one of the connectors between this is
the dr
glob and uh
man and who's treating manfred but also
treating
jack bolan and glob says it's a massive
problem for the schizophrenic to relate
to the
school why because
the schizophrenic very often deals
through people through their unconscious
this is this is glob's
view on things the teaching machines of
course have no shadow personalities
what they are is all on the surface
since the schizophrenic is a custom
constantly to ignore the surface
and look beneath he draws a blank he's
simply
unable to understand them and that would
be a significant
problem would it not so you know bolin
is is suffering from this and he goes
through some
some episodes by the end he's pretty
much going to be
okay but we have we have a couple other
characters who are are really important
in this and one of them is arnie cott
this union boss totally you know like
confident he goes from success to
success
he runs things up there on on mars
but he uses manfred
who he suspects of having some some
psionic abilities some
some pre-cog you know precognition
abilities and he wants to be able to
communicate with this autistic kid who
won't say anything other than
double gubble and so he details jack to
work on this
and arnie realizes that
he can use what's going on to do the
time slip to go
backwards in time and unscrew up the
situation that he's in but when he does
that
he loses his his sort of aura of
confidence
he becomes touched by the other
characters and he starts to see the
world
like they do as someplace that's not
just you know his his oyster but
someplace that could be kind of scary he
starts to have
the desire to not be touched by other
people
manfred himself is you know considered
to be a very
serious case and you know glob
suspects what's going on
so here's what glob says um
here here we go uh arnie said you told
me on the phone you've got a theory
about the schizophrenic being out of
phase in time
yes it's a derangement in the interior
time sense dr glob had all three of them
listening
we've got to get to total experimental
verification but that will come
and so you know arne says that's very
interesting
could such slow motion chambers be built
to allow
a kind of communication and jack says no
doubt and then glob says
and sensors to get the patient out of
the chamber into the real world sight
hearing
jack says it could be done and so arnie
says
could the schizophrenic be running so
fast compared to us in time he's
actually
in what is to us the future would that
account for his precognition and glob
says
yes so glob says now here's the rub and
autism especially the faculty of
interpersonal
communication is drastically impaired
and that's the
issue for um for manfred
you know he says in child autism there
is no language at all at least no spoken
language
possibly totally personal private
thoughts but no words
and as it turns out this this is right
at least in the framework of the story
manfred is living in a future that
is a terrible awful world
that they're hurtling towards and he's
already seeing himself as an old man
dying in these apartment buildings that
have been built
on these mountains of mars he's able to
get out of it
and at the very end of the the uh
narrative he shows up as an old man
along with the bleak men the native
residents of mars
and he's uh so old that that it's you
know
an old man from the chest on up the rest
a tangle of pumps and hoses and dials
and he says jack bolan
uh i am here to say goodbye to my mother
now i can thank you and then jack says
well i didn't do anything for you and he
says yes i think so
in my opinion you tried to communicate
with me many years ago
i appreciate that he says it wasn't long
ago
this is jack have you forgotten you came
back to us it was just today
this is your distant past when you were
a boy and so
you know there has been another time
slip
going on within the narrative framework
let's talk now about clans of the alpine
elf and moon right
so there's a few things to say about
this it is as we
remarked a moon that was at one time a
hospital colony
for mental patients and the un
has taken an interest in it and earth is
going to try to take it over
and uh mary rittensdorf the the renowned
marriage counselor slash you know
psychoanalyst
is being brought in on this and
you know what we hear about it is we
here's her words we don't know enough
yet perhaps
when we know more but it's not a
subculture
these people living on the moon it has
no tradition it's a society of mentally
ill individuals and their offspring that
came into existence
only 25 years ago you can't dignify it
by comparing it with and she mentions
other cultures what values
could mentally ill people develop and in
such a short time
now her boss says if they've developed
any kind of stable viable culture we'll
leave them
alone but that determination is up to
these experts like dr rittensdorf
and um you know she realizes that she's
being played a little bit the goal is
actually
to use them to you know perhaps get
something new
you know something to study and
there's another passage later on in the
work where she is um
discussing how these seven classes of
people on this moon
have managed to become clans
where they live in their own settlements
and you know they live with others of
their kind so
she here i'll read what she says
on both sides of her heebs that's what
they call themselves a corruption of
what
of the obviously accurate diagnostic
category
hebrew phrenic gazed with vacuous
silliness grinning without comprehension
right
and then she goes on and she says at
least these people are harmless
hebrew phrenics at all their stages of
deterior deterioration
lack the capacity to act out aggression
there were
far more omnimous on ominous derangement
syndromes to be on the lookout for
right and who are they well the mains
the manic depressives
who in their manic phase could be highly
destructive and then she says
the destructiveness of the manics would
be limited to impulse
with the acute paranoid a system
systematized
and permanent hostility could be
anticipated the paranoid possessed an
analytical
calculating quality he had a good reason
for his actions
and you know she goes on and talks about
this a little bit more and says the
paranoid seems rational
um but they are driven by a sort of
deranged aff activity
uh and then she goes on and and she's
talking to this this simulacrum and she
says
the ma manics would be the warrior class
without fear
uh the paranoids would function as
statement
they'd be in charge of developing
political ideology and social programs
they'd have the overall world view
the simple schizophrenics would
correspond to the poet class the schizes
as they're called
some of them would be religious
visionaries that would be some of the
hebes the hebes would be inclined to
produce ascetic saints
the schizophrenics would produce
dogmatists
the pop the those with polymorphics
schizophrenia simplex
would be the creative members of the
societies producing the new
ideas and then there could be those with
overvalent ideas psychiatric disorders
that were advanced forms of milder
obsessive compulsive neurosis these
would be the clerk and office holders of
the society the ritualistic
functionaries
the cons their conservativism would
balance the radical quality of the
polymorphic schizophrenics
right and then there is also one other
group the depths the depressives and
each of them
lives in their particular settlement and
they work together
and they don't want to be turned back
into hospital patients now there's this
long back and forth discussion about
whether this will
or should be the case and what it
revolves around
is whether they are functional
a little bit later in the book there is
this really interesting discussion
between
her and some of the other people
including
one of the paranoids
and she here we go
she's saying you you have to understand
this was a legitimate hospital
you must include the realization of this
as a factor in any plans you might make
regarding us
i'm speaking the plain simple truth and
then bain says
quest veritas pardon dr rittensdorf said
bane says what is truth
here's the the key thing hasn't it
occurred to you doctor that in the last
decade we
here might have risen above our initial
problems of group adaptation
and become adjusted or whatever term you
prefer
in any case capable of possessing
adequate interpersonal relationships
as you're witnessing here in this
chamber surely if we can work together
we are not sick there's no other test
that you can apply
other than that of group work ability
and she says well you're a unified
against a common enemy but i don't think
you can actually manage
a society on your your own
and you know he says you know no
actually we we have been
managing for quite some time now that's
a really interesting idea isn't it
if the sign or
or the criterion for mental illness is
not being able to maintain healthy
interpersonal relations
over time in ways that are beneficial
if they've managed to do that because
they've turned their tendencies
into a new way of living then
it would in in some way be a sign of
rigidity and perhaps even insanity to
insist that no no they're
only mental patients and can only ever
be
that and so that's that's some
interesting stuff from clans of the
elephant moon
uh turns out of course rittendorff
herself is is
sadistic and uh you know bites people
um when she's having sex and there's all
sorts of other
interesting things about her personality
which shows you the sort of stereotype
of the um insane psychiatrist
let's talk about the other two so we
have maze of death right
and this is a really important
one so they
manufacture in their their group
whatever you want to call it delusion
that they're having which they've
induced
they manufacture an entire theology
which is uh quite interesting there's
all this discussion of
prayers and and i think we can see some
of this
through the eyes and and ears of some of
the characters
so tony dunklewelt who is going into
these trance states he's a young man
he's you know he's created a new
theology on top of this theology
so he says
here we go tony said there's a deity
above the deity
one who embraces all four what for for
what
the four manifestations the manufacturer
right the and then he's he he's also
going to talk about the intercessor and
the you know the walker
um right and so this is part of their
theology but then there's also the
form destroyer and he says
she says you mean you can commune with a
god that combines the form destroyer
with the other three but that's not
possible tony
they're good gods and the form destroyer
is evil and he says i know that's why i
can see what i see is so keen
a god above god which no one can see but
me
again by degrees he shifted back into
his trance he
ceased speaking to her she says how can
how come you can see something that no
one else can and still call it real
spectowsky who who wrote this book that
they you know all
have and the book is sort of like the
first scientific theology out there
saying yes god is real
and here's how god is manifested how can
you see it
and and nobody else can spectowsky
didn't say anything about such a super
deity
so you know the the intimation here is
that tony himself is
is insane um and it turns out that he is
because he ends up killing
uh people he ends up killing the
custodian
with a a sword but the sword comes to
him
through through prayer there's also an
interesting
passage here right before
some of some of the other things happen
so this is maggie walsh who's the
theologian
she says you know spektowski talks about
us being prisoners of our own
preconceptions and expectations and that
one of the conditions of the curse
is to remain mired in the quasi-reality
of these pro-cliff
proclivities without ever seeing reality
as it actually is
frazier the psychologist says nobody
ever sees reality as it actually is it's
kant proof space and time are modes of
perception
did you know that did you know that mr
marine biologist
right and then maggie says spektowski
says ultimately we can see reality as it
is when the intercessor releases us from
our world and condition when the curse
is lifted from us right
so this is part of their
mutual delusion um
now there's a really interesting passage
later on
and this is uh after
they're looking at russell who's the new
arrival
and he doesn't have a copy of
spektowski's book
and here here it goes there was one
class of people who did not carry a copy
of spektowski's book
did not carry it because they were not
allowed to read it the ostriches
shut up in the planet-wide avery at
terra
those who lived in the sand pile because
they had crumbled under the enormous
psychological pressure suffered while
emigrating
there's something about about traveling
that destroys the psyche that puts us at
at you know greater risk for whatever
latent problems we've got that we had
you know more or less tucked away to
come to the fore
since all the other planets of the soul
system were uninhabitable emigration
meant a trip to another star system
and the insidious beginning for many of
the space illness of loneliness
and uprootedness right and as it turns
out
they are ostriches they are there on
earth
they have been experimented upon and
they are not really
functional people as it turns out
you know there's this earlier discussion
in it where fraser is talking about
his testing of all these people says
that that you know none of them are
particularly good they all show
obsessive traits
they're all hyper obsessive and you know
he he includes himself in that so
there's some interesting stuff about you
know insanity
reality perception who's actually in the
know about things going on there
culminating of course in finding out
that they're they're actually
in a virtual reality game toy that
that's allowing them to
deal with their crappy life situation
and then finally we have three stigmata
of palmer eldritch
here we again see that that colonization
sucks
and it's hard on people and
they end up needing to take a drug
that allows them to you know get into
these
these um false realities right
and also to think about
um you know how things are are
how things are developing
within this this fake world so there's
this really interesting
discussion between one of the main
characters
who has now been drafted and is going
out to these hovels
in these colonies right and he's being
um talked to by this woman fran
right and fran is actually a plant she's
supposed to be like you know in a spy
network and she says that um
and what is it that they they believe so
you know they're chewing candy
and she says he says i'll chew in unison
with you
but let's not do anything while we're
there on tara that you you know oh
there's
she's actually saying that just because
we're pat and walt and not ourselves
that doesn't give us license
and he says then you admit we really go
to earth they'd argue this point and it
was cardinal many times
in the past so these people think that
by
participating in this this psycho
hallucinogenic
melding that they are becoming pat
and walt and enjoying all these consumer
items and the chance to
you know screw around and experience uh
the beach and all of these really nice
things palmer eldritch is coming back
from proxima with a new thing choozy
and suzy is a different kind of drug
and as it turns out it's not really
palmer eldritch who came back
it's a being that has inhabited has
devoured him has used him
and now wants to take over our space
our minds and not just with this drug
but by becoming us and us becoming it
now where where is reality and where is
appearance where is insanity in
all of that as it turns out in in the
three stigmata
it won't people wind up becoming palmer
eldritch he's inhabiting
and colonizing our
reality and that's what's so terrifying
about it because he's not
a he's not a good god in doing that
right transubstantiation
is transubstantiation with something bad
and so
in order to deal with the malaise of
being out there in the colonies we
welcome or accept something else that's
even
worse so this is you know a set of
novels we could look at other ones
as well but i think those four are
really
good for tying these these two key
themes of
colonization of the solar system and the
interstellar system
and whatever we want to call it insanity
mental illness disorder or
revelation and adaptation to
a reality that itself is kind of crazy
[Music]
you